CHRISTINE BREINER: Welcome
back to recitation.
In this video I would like
us to use Green's theorem
to compute the
following integral,
where it's the integral
over the curve C,
where C is the
circle drawn here.
So the circle is oriented so
the interior is on the left
and it's centered at the point
where x equals a, y equals 0.
So the integral-- you can read
it but I will read it also
for you-- it's the integral of 3
x squared y squared dx plus 2 x
squared times the
quantity 1 plus x*y dy.
So you are supposed
to use Green's theorem
to compute that.
And why don't you
pause the video,
give it a shot, and then when
you're ready to see my solution
you can bring the video back up.
OK, welcome back.
Well, what we're
going to do, obviously
to use Green's theorem
to compute this--
because I gave you a big
hint that you're supposed
to use Green's
theorem, because we
have an integral
over a closed curve.
And what we're
going to do is now
take the integral of another
certain integrand-- obviously
related in some way to
this-- over the region
that I will shade here.
So we're interested in
this shaded region now.
So let me write down what
Green's theorem is and then
we'll put in the
important parts.
OK, so just to remind you, I'm
not going to write down all
the hypotheses of Green's
theorem that we need,
but the point that I want
to make is that if we start
the integral over this closed
curve C of M*dx plus N*dy we
can also integrate over the
region that C encloses of N sub
x minus M sub y dy dx.
So that is ultimately
what we're going to do.
And so in this case
again, as always,
M is going to be the function
associated with the dx portion.
It's the i-th component
of the vector field.
And N is going to be the
function associated here
with the dy.
That's standard obviously.
So now what we want
to do is transform
what we have there into
something that looks like this.
So the region-- I'm just
going to keep calling it
R for the moment-- but the
region R, you'll notice,
is the thing that I
shaded in the drawing.
And so now let's compute
what this is-- well
you have the
capacity to do that.
That's just some straight
taking derivative.
So I'm just going to write down
what it is and not show you
all the individual pieces.
So I'll just write
down what you get
and then the simplified version.
So you get 6 x squared
y plus 4x is N sub x.
And then M sub y is
negative 6 x squared y.
And I'm going to call dy*dx, I'm
just going to refer to it now
as dA, because that makes
it a lot easier to write.
Oh, I guess I should call this--
well, dA, this is the area.
The volume form there.
So this simplifies and I
just get the integral of 4x
over this region dA.
Now this-- you saw
an example of this
in lecture of how to deal
with these types of problems.
At this point, if
I really wanted to,
I could figure out what the
bounds are in that region
R in terms of x and y, and
I could do a lot of work
and integrate it all, or I
could remember one simple fact.
Which is that if
I have-- I think
you see it in class as x
bar-- the center of mass
should be equal to
1 over the volume
of the region times the integral
of x dA over the region.
That's what we know.
This should be-- this maybe
doesn't look like a V.
But so in this case,
volume is area, isn't it?
Maybe I should write area,
that might make you nervous.
So if I take the area--
I could just say A of R--
if I take the area,
1 over the area,
and then I multiply by the
integral of x over R with
dy*dx, with respect to dA,
then I get the center of mass.
Well, let's look at what--
in this picture, what
is the center of mass here?
If I want to balance this
thing on a pencil tip,
if I want to balance this
disc-- assuming the density is
everywhere the same--
on a pencil tip,
where am I going
to put the pencil?
I'm going to put it
right at the center.
The x-value there is a,
the y-value there is 0.
So if I had the y center
of mass, I would want 0.
But I want the x center
of mass, so I want a.
This x bar is actually
equal to, from the picture,
is equal to a.
And now let's notice
what I've done.
I have taken-- I had
this quantity here-- I've
taken this quantity
except for the 4
and I have a way of
writing explicitly
what this quantity
is without actually
doing any of the integration.
I haven't done any sophisticated
things at this point
except know what the
center of mass is.
So also what is the
area of the region?
I'm going to need that.
The area of the region--
it's a circle of radius a.
So the area is pi a squared.
So this quantity
is pi a squared.
And all this together tells me
that the integral of x over R
dA, if I solve for this part,
I get a times pi a squared.
So I get pi a cubed.
And that only differs from
our answer by one thing.
There's a scalar--
you multiply by 4
and that gives us what we want.
I said differs from our answer.
Differs from what we
want by one thing.
We just multiplied by 4 there,
so we multiply by 4 here.
So in fact-- maybe there looks
like there was a little magic
here, so let me point out some
of the key points at the end.
I started off knowing I
was trying to integrate 4x
over the region R.
And R in this case
was a circle centered at
(a, 0) and of radius a.
And then I said, well, I
don't want to do a lot of work
for this.
So I'm going to
not cheat, but I'm
going to use my knowledge
of the center of mass
to make this easier.
So the center of
mass is equal to 1
divided by the area of the
region times the integral of x
over the region.
So I want to find the
integral of x over the region,
I just solve for the integral
of x over the region.
I just solve for that part.
The center of mass-- from
just looking at the picture
and understanding what
the center of mass
means-- the center of mass
in the x component is a.
The area is pi a squared.
So I end up with
a pi a cubed when
I solve for the integral of x.
And then because I wanted
the integral of 4x,
I just multiply by 4.
And so the final answer
is actually 4 pi a cubed.
So what I was trying
to find, if you
remember, was I was
trying to find the value,
when I integrated
over this curve,
of a certain vector field.
And that one was going to be a
little messy to do it that way.
But Green's theorem,
actually there's
a lot of cancellation
which makes it much easier,
and then the center of
mass is a nice little trick
to use at the end.
And then the calculation
is quite simple.
So I think that's
where I'll stop.